Welcome to Jurassic Warehouse.
This is Stegosaur.
Stegosaur is for a Jurassic World exhibition.
This is our T-Rex.
She tends to steal the show and dominate the workshop.
I keep thinking one of these things is gonna eat me.
Yeah.
Sonny Tilders hails from Melbourne and cofounded Creature Technology.
Since its birth in 2006, the company has specialized in making giant robotic animals...
...and has ended up as one of the biggest animatronics companies around.
The creature team is made up of movie special effects artists...
...who needed work during down periods...
...and their first project was a live show called Walking with Dinosaurs...
...that ended up as the highest-grossing touring event in the world in 2010.
They've been in high demand ever since,...
...making rideable dragons, a full-sized King Kong and cuddlier creations...
...like these giant stuffed animals for the Sochi Olympics.
Vladimir Putin still likes to cuddle the bunny rabbit on the right.